[Music]
good morning actor mejía greets you today is
wednesday may 20 clark county set
its date to reopen the
economy and relax restrictions in
less than two weeks as you will remember the
original plan was to reopen the county
when at least 60% of  the population
was vaccinated, however, in their
decision on Tuesday, the commissioners
unanimously voted to get rid of
that plan and decided that as
of June 1, vaccinated people
will not have to distance themselves or wear
masks, in addition, the capacity will
return to 100% and today a new one opens
vaccination clinic for people
over 12 years of age the clinic
was originally giving vaccinations at the
ancor hotel and will now be offering
vaccinations for people with appointments at this
new site which is located within the
hospital itself by the charles tina and
more vaccination fairs continue to pop up
work for those people looking for
employment the hotel the street announced that it
will have a fair in the area of  buffet
from 10 am to 4 pm tomorrow
thursday the hotel company says that it
will be offering bonuses for certain
positions to see the list of
open places or to apply you can visit
the hotel page the hotel south point
also offers job opportunities
its fair  labor is tomorrow also from 9
am to 4 pm inside one of their
halls and they will be raffling various prizes
and now a look at the
weather forecast again we will reach
temperatures within 90 degrees
for today wednesday gusts of
35 miles per  afternoon hour
stronger winds tonight and thursday i have
a drop in temperature
dropping to the low seventies by
friday thank you for your time i am from
mejía this was your brief
innings briefing in spanish
[Music]
no